welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and marvel's shanxi
has a new trailer revealing its martial
arts hero in a mystery plot
involving the iron man foes the ten
rings or should i say
marvel already had cosmic knuckle bling
soap ten
bracelets this movie looks so great and
i'm gonna break down this trailer shot
by shot for everything that you might
have missed a ton of cool easter eggs
and the really cool reason behind this
ring change and most importantly why
they waited to release this trailer days
before the finale of the falcon the
winter soldier let's get started
okay we meet simulu as shengshi not to
get too um actually about the
pronunciation it's just how kevin feige
said in december
and the legend of the ten rings shangshi
is the martial arts hero introduced to
marvel comics in 1973 initially to
capitalize on the popularity of bruce
lee kung fu
movies like enter the dragon this film
appears to have some similar fighting
tournament elements with an eclectic mix
of fighters overseen by a crime lord
with mystical powers i'm speaking of
course of shang shi's father
wen wu tony liang aka the mandarin
leader of the mcu criminal organization
the ten rings in the comics shangshi's
father was originally the villain fu
manchu
a character with a problematic history
later renamed
zhang zhu but this film is merging that
father-son relationship with the classic
villain to iron man into shangshi the
mandarin
and yes this is the real mandarin as
opposed to the imposter mandarin actor
trevor slattery in iron man 3
the all hail the king short showed
slattery being broken out of prison by a
vengeful tin rings operative but you
took his name
and now he wants it back
the terrorist raza ran one faction of
the ten rings in the first iron man that
agent who gave ivan vanko his travel
documents and iron man 2 was confirmed
to be 10 rings and then an ant-man one
of the interested buyers of pymtech i
had a 10 rings neck tattoo so yeah these
guys have been around since the
beginning
always in the shadows always looking for
a new weapon they can get their hands on
now marvel dropped this trailer the same
week of the finale
of the falcon in the winter soldier
which has been teasing a mysterious
power broker
operating out of majorport in southeast
asia whom i have been theorizing in many
videos could be connected to the 10
rings maybe even the mandarin himself
there's actually a very big clue later
in this trailer that confirms shanxi
is headed to madrapore i mean i could
definitely see marvel setting up a power
broker reveal with a
shang cheese trailer all about this
mysterious mandarin and it's not like
i've ever been wrong about a marvel
series finale before
but here at the beginning of the trailer
shanxi revisits the training center of
his youth the wooden post that he would
have to punch
bare knuckle similar to the brutal
training of paimei and kill bill volume
2
uh don't worry buddy if you ever get
buried alive at least you'll know
exactly what to do next clip
i gave you 10 years to live your life
and where did that get you
so for the past 10 years xiangxi has
been living a modest life in san
francisco he sleeps in a garage he air
dries his clothes he does these
alternating push-ups i love how on his
wall is a poster for the hilarious
and awesome martial arts film kung fu
hustle which should be noted features a
fighter with wrist rings but i love the
misdirect here of the fancy car pulling
up just like the sweet rides driven by
past marvel heroes like tony stark
steven strange natasha romanov t'challa
but here the focus shifts to the valet
who is our hero
aquafina plays his friend katie ronnie
chang plays another friend
you see them singing karaoke with the
verse over sideways and under
from aladdin's a whole new world because
disney actually the music we're hearing
in this trailer is a new track by rapper
jackson wang
and there's one interesting lyric that's
going to be important later in this
breakdown and during this section we
also hear the voice of win woo saying
i gave you 10 years to live your life so
my assumption is that shanxi ran away
from his abusive father but despite all
that his father has been
always watching like someone else we
know i mean i'm sorry i just feel really
good about that theory anyway next clip
he walked in my shadow
so we flashed back to shanghi's very
violent training under his father along
with this figure this
is death dealer leashing lin in the
comics an mi6 assassin who secretly
works for fumanchu and with the
character changing to the mandarin in
this movie that's who they now work for
nearby there's this poster showing a
human body perhaps
indicating pressure points and pain
centers which ironically should be used
to teach these warriors but in this case
it's being applied on this young child
but eventually the kid can punch this
post over and over
pummeling out sawdust as an adult shank
she reflects back on all that pain that
brought him as a child another memory
shows them with his father who's wearing
these wrist rings
five on each wrist these are the ten
rings now in the comics the ten rings
are worn on each finger
each of them pieces of alien mcclue and
tech that each contain the soul of some
ancient cosmic warrior and each ring
contains a different function there's
the matter rearranger ring or remaker
which allows manipulation of the
molecular structure of matter even
turning air into poison gas or air into
solid blocks around enemies the impact
beam ring or influence which projects
concussive beams
the vortex beam ring or spin creates a
vortex of air enabling levitation
the disintegration beam ring or spectral
enables disintegration but requires a 20
minute recharge
there's a black light ring aka
nightbringer creates an area of darkness
also something you think will look cool
from spencer's gifts which just shows
your sister's friends how disgusting you
are the white light ring
or demonic allowing manipulation of
electromagnetic energy of light gravity
fields image projection and benefits
from various socioeconomic privileges as
the black light ring has been
historically denied there's the flame
blast ring aka incandescence projects
fire
the mento intensifier ring a gay the
liar amplifies psionic power making you
a professor x-style telepath the
electro-blast ring a
lightning projects electrical energy and
the ice blast ring aka zero
projects extreme cold and prostate
responses on twitter now here we only
get a taste of these powers ruining a
game of mahjong it looks like but
elsewhere in the trailer when wu blasts
a path through an
army he appears to bend water he floats
but yeah we may get to see all of these
in action
now why are they these wrist ring
bracelets instead of the rings they are
in the comics well you could say that
marvel already showed us cosmic space
jewelry worn on the fingers
and which would require a bit of a
redesign and yes in some chinese martial
arts like hungar
they do use similar iron rings to help
strengthen the arms but i also like the
theory that these rings could have been
larger to fit the claws of the dragon
than feng fume the ancient mcluhan bean
from whom in the comics the mandarin
stole these ten rings now fin fang boom
is expected to appear in this film
there's a funko pop figurine
labeling him as the great protector so
perhaps he
was the original protector of these
rings when wu stole them armed himself
up with them and then set out to conquer
the world with a criminal empire
and part of shang chi's mission now
could be to have to awaken finfeng boom
in fact one of jackson wang's rap verses
in this trailer includes the line
you woke up the dragon
so there you go and then as shanxi's boy
tussles with assassins he wears this
green stone around his neck which he
also wears as an adult in san francisco
maybe he wore it as a token of his past
but this was secretly the way his father
was tracking him all this time moving on
i trained you
see the most dangerous people in the
world
couldn't kill you son
it's time for you to take your place by
my side
so ronnie chang's character takes them
to this cage fight nightclub which i
believe to be in majorport i just don't
know of any place in san francisco where
people go to watch death matches i mean
there are places where people watch each
other do
other stuff unspeakable stuff but not
like this in fact
later in this trailer shangshi stands
among the chains of this cage and if you
look past that third strap over to the
left that my friends is
the iconography of madrapore seen in the
magiforce shipyards and the license
plates in the falcon the winter soldier
episode 3.
you see the crescent moon and the star
so yes confirmed folks we are headed
back to the place where
the power broker is watching now to be
honest folks the only reason i can see
all these details is because i am
staring wide-eyed at the screen inches
away from it
moving my dumb head around trying to
find these things and i'm doing it on my
computer i'm doing it on my phone
my eyes are constantly glued to screens
screen time is basically the only time
now
and i've noticed my eyes feeling heavy
and i was actually having some problems
sleeping and i realized it was because
of too much
blue light well thanks to blue blocks
for sponsoring this video
and helping me out with this blue light
damages our eyes and leads to digital
eye strain
symptoms of digital eye strain include
blurred vision headaches dry watery eyes
for some folks that can even affect your
energy level
well blue blocks was created to fix this
problem and block
out the blue light with high quality
lenses blue blocks are evidence-backed
and made
under optics laboratory conditions in
australia they have over 40 styles of
frames incoming prescription
non-prescription and readers they have
frames for every need so go to
blueblocks.com
new rockstars or just click the link
below and you will get 20
off your order and free shipping
worldwide on orders over 115
so get your energy back sleep better and
block out the unhealthy effects of blue
light with blue blocks
that's b l u b l o x dot com slash new
rockstars or just click the link below
code automatically applied at checkout
for 20 off and thanks again to blue box
for sponsoring this video here we see
the fighter florian montiano big nasty
himself he is playing razor fist an
assassin villain from the shanxi comics
and a title carried actually by a few
different dudes later in this trailer
his blades do
extend to presumably retract into stumps
meaning he doesn't have to walk around
with these loose blades like buster from
rusted development with that hook
but in the later fight his blades do
glow with a kind of magic
and here he wears the 10 rings logo
flanked by warriors wearing the same
logo but
they were capable of finding shirts
their arms can fit into either way
suggesting that he is another mandarin
operative
perhaps sent to capture his son and
bring him back to him
and we see that happening with this
helicopter landing at win woo's fortress
you can see the ten rings logo on the
landing pad
and this guy's got a freaking army
dozens of soldiers lined up in the
courtyard and along all the battlements
military trucks and humvees
telecommunication towers and
a massive artillery turret presumably
one to take down
aircraft chongqi emerges with his father
at his side along with katie
she's along for the ride razor fist and
jai ling
shanxi's estranged sister wenwu's
daughter played here by menger zheng and
then there's this
alternate shot of win woo in much older
wardrobe and an older hair style
his head is framed perfectly in the
center of the ten rings logo now again
wenwu is ancient he's likely a
semi-immortal with these rings so
in this movie we are gonna see him
fighting in the wars from centuries past
now on the wall behind him each ring
contains a different character now i
don't know enough to translate these but
i'm thinking each could represent the
soul of the cosmic warrior contained
within each ring
actually other close-ups in this trailer
show the rings with writing appearing to
glow from within
kind of like the elfish script in the
ring of power in the lord of the rings
this writing is also visible in the
rings on the official poster for
shangshi this could be maybe telling the
history and hidden secrets contained
within each ring moving on
[Music]
[Applause]
okay we see the arm with the rings on it
clenching into a fist facing off with
this army including these
giant lions also called food dogs
they're important to buddhist culture
they're guardian lions that appear on
chinese palaces and tombs to guard the
souls of the ancestors we actually get a
really good look at these later in the
trailer in action
and here there appear to only be two of
them as these statues are often in pairs
at structure entrances
and then shanxi faces off with death
dealer who leaps from a helicopter into
the skyscraper
all these stunts and wire work camera
movement is coming from cinematographer
bill pope famous for his work on the
matrix films which also incorporated
some hong kong filmmaking stunts and
wire work including
a memorable dramatic leap from a
helicopter into a skyscraper and they
move almost too fast to see the action
here but chongxie does knock that dagger
from death dealer's hand and catches it
midair on to the next clip
you can't outrun
who you really are
so director destin daniel crenton and
bill pope are creating some
beautiful imagery here mixing the
natural beauty of this bamboo forest
with these great costumes and some fluid
wire work
actually very reminiscent of angley's
crouching tiger hidden dragon this whole
genre of story is called wussya
apologies
the pronunciation's bad it refers to
chinese martial arts heroes on these
romantic crusades in these kind of
picturesque settings you can see when
woo soaring down
in this ballet-like duel and you can see
those 10 rings on his arms he's going
towards this interesting female figure
which i'm thinking could be michelle yeo
who of course starred in crouching tiger
hidden dragon she's so great in that
she's so great in everything and she
actually appeared already in the mcu as
the ravager elita oguard and guardians
of the galaxy vol 2.
now more shots of this ancient war shows
a warrior using shields as a ramp
springboard and all around them are
these small flying creatures that
kinda look like dragons now it's
interesting how his spear
and the arrows that descend upon them
all appear to glow as if these ancient
weapons all carry a kind of magic to
them jai lang fights her brother in the
cage match and we see that she
too wears the green stone around her
neck perhaps she feels bitter towards
her brother for being able to live free
for 10 years only now to be the prodigal
son returning
favored by their father to be the heir
over her despite her ongoing loyalty
shangshi fights his father directly as
the rings blow and then another shot
shows his car chase with chongqi perched
on the side
as they pass these humvees maybe this is
an escape attempt from the ten rings
compound
and then that shot i mentioned earlier
of win woo in the distant past
marching through a hole that he
apparently blasted through this army of
defenders as he claims this castle now
based on that mountainous terrain behind
it this might be the same fortress that
he lives in and uses in the modern day
this could be a flashback showing how he
initially captured it
next clip
who are you
[Music]
[Applause]
god i love the action here these
rhythmic double backhand punches
immediately followed by a jump kick
taking both dudes down
feels very jackie chan and all this
slapstick stunt work actually the dude
on the left his cheek remains smushed in
from that kick you really feel the
impact there but my favorite thing about
this
notice that dude sitting on this bus
he's later filming the chaos with his
phone this is comedian zack cherry
who played the street vendor in
spider-man homecoming who told
spider-man to do a flip
flip you may remember cherry did a
segment on stephen colbert going to new
york comic-con trying to get his own
marvel spin-off film
and now his dreams are closer to coming
true he's an officially a recurring
marvel character like gamer aaron aka
newmaster69 i love seeing this kind of
thing now the editing here makes it look
like chongqi
answers katie's who are you with this
fierce pose though i'm assuming this is
a different part of the fight because
katie's looking at the back of the bus
with the driver way behind her and then
a chongchi's shot
he's now right next to the driver for
his pose but i just love how this poses
right before the bus
enters this tunnel making me think we're
gonna see a lot of hits go down as the
tunnel lights are flashing in and out
it's gonna look awesome now thankfully
the trailer only leaves us with this
little tease of it not revealing the
great imagery we're gonna see just yet
and then after the title reveal we move
on to the last clip
we make a good team yeah katie takes the
wheel of the city bus the back half is
torn off as we saw in set video from
last year as a garbage truck essentially
is running it off the road in girodelli
square in san francisco
wrecking a bunch of nice cars that she
and shanghai might have had to valet
i would love to get some reference to
the chases in ant-man and the wasp which
went down
not far from here in san francisco even
if they quickly pass a giant hello kitty
pez dispenser that's been turned into a
playground or something now we see this
woman getting saved by her purse strap
actually by a thirst trap another lady
is on his shoulders while a third grabs
a hold of his leg
okay i'm thinking this one just threw
herself on him oh i'm losing my balance
too
uh ma'am you were buckled in i saw you
and then the garbage truck driver climbs
up there too
uh i wanna i want a hug
this feels so good hey this is our
anarchy assembled shirt you can get this
at newrockstarsmerch.com and look like a
true fan of the fact of the winter
soldier which after watching this
trailer i am even more
excited for that finale follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars subscribe to me rockstars
here on youtube for breakdowns of
everything marvel thank you for watching
now i'm gonna try to do some of those
push-ups oh oh i i'm breaking everything
[Music]
you